[Música]
hola bienvenidos a aqui américa el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente yo soy natalia
cabrera parada y esto es lo que veremos
hoy
empezamos en el sur del continente en
colombia porque la comisión de la verdad
divulgó su informe sobre el conflicto
armado tras tres años de investigación
concluyó que el 80% de las víctimas eran
civiles
el presidente saliente iván duque no
asistió al evento mientras que el
presidente electo gustavo petro si en un
claro gesto del compromiso de cada uno
con la implementación del acuerdo de paz
con la extinta guerrilla de las farc
íbamos a méxico porque la lucrativa
industria del aguacate está llamando la
atención de los cárteles del
narcotráfico que están buscando obtener
una tajada los campesinos de michoacán
revelaron a un grupo de france 24 que
están siendo extorsionados para poder
sacar sus cosechas y tras dos años de
pausa debido a las restricciones para
contener la propagación del cob y 19 la
fiesta más importante de la amazonía
brasileña vuelve el festival de paran
teens nuestros enviados especiales
mostrarán un informe de allí
y empezamos con la cifra de la semana o
las cifras son las que deja el informe
de la comisión de la verdad sobre los
más de 50 años de conflicto armado en
colombia 77 millones de personas fueron
desplazadas forzosamente
450 mil 664 fueron asesinadas 121 mil
778 están desaparecidas y 50 mil 770
fueron secuestradas si bien el documento
no tiene consecuencias judiciales
cumplió una meta del acuerdo de paz
firmado en 2016 entre el gobierno
colombiano entonces a la cabeza de juan
manuel santos y que le valió el premio
nobel de paz y la extinta guerrilla de
las farc ahora tiene por delante de dos
meses de socialización y siete años de
seguimiento para que el estado
implemente las recomendaciones que de él
se desprenden luís muñoz y leonel to
seguinos prepararon el siguiente informe
desde bogotá
hay futuro si hay verdad es la primera
frase de los hallazgos y recomendaciones
del informe de la comisión de la verdad
en colombia así habló su presidente
francisco de roux y nuestro mar y a 17
años darle un minuto para honrar a cada
una de las víctimas
sin la presencia del presidente iván
duque pero con el presidente electo
gustavo petro este prometió leer las
recomendaciones que salen de los
hallazgos las generaciones de 200 años
de soledad' si tienen
oportunidad una segunda oportunidad
junto a the roof nueve comisionados el
español carlos beristáin ya ha
participado en otras comisiones antes
rescate el buen nombre de millones de
personas y es una buena noticia también
para otros países además de víctimas del
conflicto también estuvieron antiguos
victimarios como rodrigo londoño ex
comandante de las farc en la medida en
que se recuerdan las recomendaciones el
ave que situaría el el horror que ver el
conflicto para que no se vuelva a
repetir la comisión de la verdad surgió
de los acuerdos de paz entre el estado y
las farc de 2016 forma parte del sistema
integral para la paz
juliette de rivero representante de la
alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos en colombia habló para
france24 donde esperamos que sean las
víctimas realmente las que escriban la
historia de colombia y que por fin
podamos rechazar la violencia entre los
hallazgos se encontró que el 80 por
ciento de las víctimas del conflicto han
sido civiles
la comisión habló durante más de tres
años con más de 30 mil víctimas pese a
todo para el escritor y profesor
fernando ayala hay esperanza no es de
funeral para colombia si no es un día de
renacimiento real de haberlo hecho si
hubiera un relato histórico que trata de
entender lo que pasó para que el
conflicto por fin termine
y sigamos en ecuador para revisar otras
noticias de las américas de esta semana
los 18 días de caos el gobierno y los
líderes indígenas firmaron un acuerdo
que pone fin a las protestas
antigubernamentales
gracias a la mediación de la iglesia
católica y luego de que el presidente
guillermo lazos se diera a varias de las
demandas de los manifestantes las
conversaciones habían sido suspendidas
esta misma semana tras la muerte de un
soldado la crisis puso a la su al borde
de la destitución en la asamblea por no
haber logrado desactivar el movimiento
de protesta en su contra pese a haber
hecho varias concesiones
y concluyó en chile- la redacción de la
nueva carta magna por parte de la
convención constitucional tras recibir
el visto bueno del presidente gabriel
boric la constitución que nació tras el
estallido social de 2018 y reemplazará
al actual que data de la era pinochet
será sometida a un plebiscito con voto
obligatorio el 4 de septiembre
y nos vamos al norte del continente a
eeuu que tang y brawn jackson juró como
jueza de la corte suprema convirtiéndose
en la primera mujer afrodescendiente en
ocupar un puesto en el alto tribunal de
eeuu jackson se une a la corte en un
momento crucial por sus recientes
decisiones sobre el aborto el porte de
armas y el cambio climático que han
despertado la desconfianza de una parte
de los estadounidenses sin embargo su
ingreso no cambia la tendencia
conservadora de la corte 6 a 3
y vamos a mexico del estado de michoacán
es el mayor productor del mundo de
aguacates cada año el país
norteamericano produce más de 18
millones de toneladas de la que se ha
convertido en la sexta fruta que más se
consume en el mundo lo que ha llamado la
atención de los cárteles del
narcotráfico que buscan obtener parte de
las ganancias nos lo cuenta nuestro
equipo en terreno
josé luís mata sigue de cerca cómo sus
aguacates maduran
de esta forma basar como les digo en dos
meses ya está lista para el corte este
año los precios del aguacate están en
aumento hasta superar un dólar por kilo
en los supermercados de méxico y de eeuu
como la mayoría de los cultivadores jose
luis mata exporta la mayoría de su
cosecha a su vecino del norte primera
calidad es por exportación lo que sobra
es por el mercado nacional
en febrero la industria del aguacate
tuvo una semana difícil mientras
visitaba una granja de michoacán un
inspector estadounidense recibió
amenazas por teléfono como consecuencia
eeuu suspendió las importaciones de
aguacates mexicanos durante una semana
el crimen organizado escudriña las
raíces de esta industria lucrativa los
cárteles quieren obtener su parte del
oro verde las exportaciones de aguacate
representan más de 3 mil millones de
dólares al año
bajo condición de anonimato los
campesinos nos dijeron que la extorsión
ya no es un secreto el crimen organizado
en términos económicos ya es un cartel
es quien determina los precios por su
incidencia en la cosecha en la
producción en la distribución en la
venta del producto es un mercado muy
atractivo a diferencia de la droga por
ejemplo que tiene que extraer insumos
del extranjero que tiene que montar
laboratorios la carrera por las
ganancias también impacta los recursos
naturales se necesitan mil litros de
agua para producir un kilo de aguacate
es ahorita del problema de agua
más complicado porque es más la demanda
igual un pozo es para abastecer a todo
lo que es el ejido son muy varios varios
vertederos el cultivo de aguacate no
puede mantener este ritmo según benjamín
revuelta un profesor de la universidad
de morelia quien advierte de las
desastrosas consecuencias para el medio
ambiente tenemos impactos muy
importantes de pérdida de biodiversidad
de contaminación de aguas de reducción
de agua de
deforestación de incendios no es muy
posible que los daños ambientales que
hoy conocemos que están documentados
sean solamente la punta del iceberg y
que abajo tengamos realmente daños
ambientales mucho más importantes
durante los últimos 30 años las
actividades culturales especialmente la
producción de aguacate destruyeron
alrededor del 40 por ciento de los
bosques de michoacán
y visitemos brasil para el cierre tras
dos años de pausa debido a las
restricciones para contener la
propagación del cob y 19 la isla de
parintins celebra el mayor festival
folclórico de la amazonía es una
competencia entre dos bueyes y entre dos
colores que se celebra en el bombo drobo
construido especialmente para este
espectáculo una grandiosa ópera a cielo
abierto la cultura indígena y los
bosques tropicales son los grandes
protagonistas de la fiesta veamos más en
el informe preparado por nuestros
enviados especiales
este es el boy bomba el mayor festival
folclórico de la amazonía tras dos años
de pandemia está de vuelta
[Risas]
durante tres noches la isla amazónica de
parent ins es un campo de batalla entre
dos bueyes el garantido y el caprichoso
el festival de parent index del mejor
festival del mundo es una fiesta de dos
bueyes que están enamorados de dos
colores el rojo y el azul
los dos grupos folclóricos compiten en
el bombo dromo una arena construida hace
34 años en el corazón de la selva
[Música]
la preparación del festival dura varios
meses en abril los artistas de cada
grupo comienzan a construir sus
esculturas gigantescas es muy complejo
porque ninguno de nosotros los artistas
somos ingenieros no estudiamos en la
universidad aprendimos a ejecutar todo
este proceso de construcción de las
figuras alegóricas en los galpones de
parís
las figuras alegóricas de parent in son
famosas por su movilidad ocho personas-
maniobran los cables desde dentro estos
artistas son muy solicitados trabajan en
el carnaval de río de janeiro e incluso
en uruguay
además se preocupan por la
sustentabilidad
ya tenemos nuestras propias técnicas
existen unos materiales que siempre
reutilizamos la mayoría de las figuras
alegóricas están hechas con aquellos
sacos que vienen de china con las
mercancías importadas en el puerto
franco de manaos zona franca en la
última edición el boy bomba atrajo a 66
mil turistas y facturó 10 es
la presentación del festival tiene una
temática indígena tiene momentos
tribales en otros se habla de ecología
de los bosques de la importancia de los
indígenas para nuestra cultura en este
ambiente festivo la pregunta es dónde se
habrá metido el buey lo encontramos en
este taller donde recibe los últimos
retoques
ponga durante 30 años marquinho dio vida
al voy caprichoso es un trabajo duro
porque ahí abajo hace 60 grados son dos
horas y son dos horas y media de
espectáculo conseguimos aguantar mucho
tiempo porque nos preparamos para eso
hacemos muchos movimientos tenemos una
excelente forma física y resistencia y
resistencia toda la familia trabaja en
la confección del buey hace tiempo
marquinho pasó el testigo a su hijo todo
esa fiesta toda la fiesta acontece en
función del buey
los hinchas acuden para animar la
competición ellos vibran se emocionamos
son a unos 35 mil espectadores
asistieron cada noche al espectáculo con
el corazón en la mano el boy caprichoso
homenaje al periodista don phillips y el
ambientalista bruno pereyra asesinados
por luchar a favor de la amazonía
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa pueden ver esta y las
anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom por favor envíen me
sus comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas y
para más información de nuestro
continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]